[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tva 78 c'est le point sur
l'actualité locale et régionale tout de
suite les titres de ce mardi 25 juin la
canicule se poursuit avec des
températures qui ont encore grimpé
aujourd'hui face à cet épisode les
collectivités s'organise exemple dans ce
journal avec le dispositif yvelines
étudiants seniors déployé chaque été
depuis 2004 dans le département est la
commune d'el en cours et inauguré hier
les nouveaux locaux de son média pôle
l'espace est situé dans l'ancienne
mairie de là ville un lieu de formation
pour les enseignants et les élèves afin
de se parfaire aux usages du numérique
et la fin de saison approche pour les
salles culturelles du territoire les
affiches ne manquent pas pour autant
qu'elles sont les spectacles à ne pas
rater avant les vacances c'est à
retrouver dans notre chronique coup de
coeur on vient de l'apprendre en raison
du pic de pollution actuellement en
ile-de-france la circulation
différencier sera mise en place pour la
journée de demain dans la région seuls
les véhicules avec des vignettes
critères verte et aussi 1 à 2 et 3
pourront circuler à paris et dans les
communes limitrophes comprises dans le
périmètre intérieur de la 86è les
contrevenants s'exposent à une amende de
135 euros
la canicule qui se poursuit donc elles
s'intensifient même dans les yvelines
placés en vigilance orange par météo
france le mercure est grimpée jusqu'à 31
degrés aujourd'hui est les prévisions
pour demain 19 degrés dès le matin les
températures la nuit ne descendent
d'ailleurs pas en dessous de ce seuil
mercredi après midi ses 34 degrés
annoncés est les journées les plus
chaudes prévues cette semaine désormais
pour vendredi et samedi
en cette période pensez à bien vous
hydrater vous alimentez également est
resté dans des endroits frais et face à
cet épisode d'intenses chaleurs les
communes des yvelines ont pris quelques
dispositions fermeture annulation à
d'événements mais aussi adaptation des
emplois du temps c'est le cas pour les
agents à poissy le chesnay rocancourt ou
encore bois d'arcy
en ce moment ils commencent leur journée
plutôt pour terminer à 13 heures en
guinée organisation également dans les
sites dédiés à l'enfance et à la petite
enfance installations de climatiseurs
comme c'est le cas notamment
clayes-sous-bois et déploiement de
de son ventilateur à mantes la jolie
enfin la mise en place de salles
climatisées pour les seniors et du côté
du département des yvelines on
s'organise également cette période de
montée des températures pour en parler
marie hélène aubert bon soir dans ça
vous êtes la 6ème vice présidente du
conseil départemental délégué à
l'autonomie alors la collectivité va
déployer pour la 16e fois son dispositif
yes pour yveline étudiants en seniors le
principe c'est l'organisation cet été de
visites d'étudiants au domicile de
personnes personnes âgées
c'est un dispositif qui prend toute son
importance en cette période de canicule
oui oui tout à fait on regrette même que
ça ne soit pas déjà en place maintenant
on a vu déjà l'année dernière que la
canicule s'est annoncée au mois de juin
aussi c'est
c'est un dispositif qui mériterait
d'être étendue certainement quand on
voit maintenant les réchauffements le
réchauffement qui qui ce réchauffement
climatique qui fait des pics en dehors
des mois d'été juillet août pour lequel
le dispositif feuillets et se met en
place
vous savez qu pièce c'est bien rodé
maintenant c'est un dispositif qu'on
nous envie par tous ces 150 140 150
étudiants suivant les années qui se
déploie sur tout le territoire des
yvelines qui vont visiter les personnes
âgées à domicile qui vont voir si la
personne n'est pas trop isolé les faire
faire des ddd visite des promenades des
voix là d une visite de convivialité
pour éviter qu'elles soient isolés pour
voir si tout va bien
éventuellement faire remonter les
informations un petit peu préoccupantes
qu on pourrait remarquer non on va avoir
l'occasion d'en parler tout à l'heure un
dispositif qui est mise en place à
partir du mois de juillet on rappelle
d'ailleurs le contexte de mise en place
de ce dispositif c'est en 2004 qu'il a
été lancé
on est un an après cette grande canicule
qui a touché la france et qui a fait 15
morts c'est ça c'est la raison pour
laquelle on l'a mis en place juste après
la canicule de 2003 et depuis on se rend
compte que chaque année c'est un
bénéfice extraordinaire pour pour nos
seniors pour l' isolement mais aussi
dans des cas de canicule comme ça mais
c'est nécessaire de leur proposer chaque
année bien sûr bien sûr fait chaque
année davantage vous savez que la
population de des yvelines vieillit plus
vite qu'ailleurs c'est un grand enjeu
pour notre département
on a un très grand nombre de personnes
âgées et dans nos milieux ruraux aussi
des personnes qui sont isolées donc il
est important de pouvoir s'assurer que
tout va bien leur donner les consignes
aussi quand il fait chaud comme ça de
s'hydrater de fermer les volets de ne
pas sortir pas faire d'exercice trop
importants voilà mais alors vous avez
parlé du principe ces visites bien sûr
au domicile des personnes âgées avec des
objectifs on l'a compris plus profond
c'est d'entretenir ce lien
intergénérationnel aussi de rompre avec
l'isolément que ressentent ces personnes
âgées
oui alors il ya des personnes âgées qui
sont isolés tout au long de l'année donc
ça c'est important d'aller les visiter
les ruines de cette saison et bien sûr
qu'elle en souffre parfois c'est une
personne qui passe le facteur simplement
qu'il passe qui est une source de deux
visites mais
c'est aussi
c'est aussi les personnes qui sont
isolées l'été simplement parce que les
voisins sont partis parce que la famille
est partie en vacances aussi
et que là il se retrouve tout seul les
dispositifs qui sont dans les communes
s'arrête aussi souvent l'été donc c'est
le moment de tous les dangers
juillet août et sur les retours vous
avez eue par rapport aux personnes âgées
aussi aux étudiants qui ont pu prendre
part à ce dispositif s'il est ce qu'ils
sont bons et ce qu'ils sortent enrichi
de cette expérience bien sûr je crois
que c'est même une évidence
ils ont l'impression d'apporter quelque
chose c'est des échanges qui sont riches
dans les deux sens tous le disent à la
sortie ils ont l'impression d'avoir eu
c'est pas seulement un job d'été c'est
c'est une source d'enrichissement
vraiment pourrait aussi et qui déclenche
des vocations vous savez ma responsable
de ces crs dans ma commune de jouy en
josas gelé recrutés après
après qu'elle ait été étudiant thiès
dans ma commune vous êtes également élu
le programme du dispositif commencent
eux s'organisent ces visites quel type
d'activité
font-ils ces seniors et ses jeunes alors
c'est des visites de convivialité
essentiellement pour distraire les
personnes seules moyenne une fois par
semaine il ya à peu près 1200 1300 1400
suivant les années personnes qui sont
visitées et puis on essaie d'organiser
aussi depuis l'année dernière parce
qu'on a un a subi un financement
complémentaire de la conférence des
financeurs pour la prévention de
l'autonomie on a un financement
supplémentaire donc on a embauché des
coordinateurs de cette opération pour
organiser des opérations collectives
ensemble que les personnes puissent
faire une visite ensemble aller à la
ferme de gally cueillir des fleurs ou
des who des légumes pouvoir aller
visiter un château pouvoir aller se
rafraîchir dans une base de loisirs
mais ensemble vous parliez de 145 jeunes
environ qui sont recrutés en emploi
saisonnier comment sont ils recrutés ces
jeunes sur entretien sur cv d'abord ils
envoient leur cv il faut qu'ils aient 20
ans il faut qu'ils aient un an de permis
et puis après c'est sûr entretien pour
vérifier que c'est pas juste un job
d'été qui cherche mais quelque chose
d'un peu plus qu'ils aient une vraie
empathie pour les personnages et sa
formation aussi une formation quelques
quelques notions de d'appréhension sur
la personne âgée comment on lui parle
comment là comment à quoi il faut faire
attention voilà
et du côté des personnes âgées c'est
pareil c'est de leur plein gré elles
s'inscrivent à ce dispositif tout à fait
elles s'inscrivent au dispositif vient
les ccs en général et il ya très très
bon retour elle en redemande
et souvent on nous dit mais pourquoi
vous ne faites pas toute l'année on y
réfléchit mais c'est pas facile des
étudiants travaillent
on découvre dans l'année donc on avait
essayé une initiative sur le mantois
avec des services civiques mais c'est
pas forcément facile donc ça fait partie
des pistes de réflexion actuellement
merci marie hélène aubert vice président
du conseil départemental délégué à
l'autonomie pour toutes les informations
sur le dispositif
yes contacté à les liens qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran et c'est l'une des
conséquences principales de la canicule
initialement prévu jeudi et vendredi le
brevet des collèges est reporté au 1er
et 2 juillet interrogé ce matin par nos
confrères de france info le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer a affirmé que les circonstances
familiales justifié serait un critère
suffisant pour passer l'examen à la
session de septembre
par exemple en cas de billets d'avion ou
de train non annulable reporter le
brevet bonne ou mauvaise décision
elle est en tout cas salué par
l'association de parents d'élèves de la
bête d'écouté de réagir pour que les
élèves puissent passer l'examen dans les
meilleures conditions évidemment nous on
regrette que ça ait été fait par voie de
presse
si précipitamment alors évidemment nous
enfin 4 du passage des épreuves en
juillet puisqu'on fait une avant que
certains parents d'élèves certaines
familles organise très en amont la en
vacances et puis évidemment il ya des
élèves qui devaient partir en voyage
scolaire de fin d'année en fait parfois
des projets qui sont en place depuis
deux ans un travail très difficile pour
les enseignants et évidemment on
envisage que c'est que ces voyages
scolaires soient maintenus alors même
qu' il y aura des épreuves déclin
national là du côté des enseignants
c'est l'inquiétude qui est de mise comme
nous le précise le syndicat snes fsu
s'agissait effectivement de réagir pour
que les élèves puissent passer l'examen
dans les meilleures conditions
évidemment nous on regrette que ça ait
été fait par voie de presse
si précipitamment alors évidemment nous
enfin 4 du passage des épreuves en
juillet puisqu'on fait il avant que
certains parents d'élèves certaines
familles organise très en amont la en
vacances et puis évidemment il ya des
élèves qui devaient partir en voyage
scolaire de fin d'année c'est parfois
des projets qui sont en place depuis
deux ans un travail
très difficile pour les enseignants et
évidemment on envisage que c'est que ces
voyages scolaires soient maintenus alors
même qu'il y aura des épreuves déclin
national
mais sur la question de faute il fait
recours ou non jeudi et vendredi pour
les autres classes le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a précisé que les
décisions seraient prises au cas par cas
selon les territoires d'autres reports
au niveau local c'est le cas du forum je
crée ma boîte qui était prévu ce jeudi
au ski cube à aiguë en cours en raison
des prévisions météo l'événement
consacré à la création et reprise
d'entreprise est déplacé au mardi 24
septembre la ville d'elancourt consacra
un bâtiment à l'éducation numérique pour
les enseignants et leurs élèves mise à
disposition de l'éducation nationale le
nouveau média pôle a été inauguré lundi
soir marie line à pishin aux deux
petites écoles communales lorsqu'elle en
cours n'était encore qu'un village
l'ancienne mairie se transforme en
médiapôle un lieu de formation au
numérique pour les scolaires et leurs
enseignants il suffit simplement
positionner l'écran au niveau de l'image
et la vidéo se déclenche su
cardiovasculaires
armé d'une tablette de la réalité
augmentée
élèves et professeurs peuvent se
déplacer dans cette salle flexible et y
découvrir ses secrets des connaissances
supplémentaires aux outils pédagogiques
novateurs là l'objectif c'est de
découvrir toutes les possibilités
d'aménagement dans une classe flexible
avec la possibilité pour les élèves de
bouger de se déplacer d'être en
mouvement parce que c'est pas forcément
à 6 ou au billet pour la premier league
se découvrir qu'on peut travailler autre
monde
inauguré le 24 juin ce média pour le
répond à l'ambition d'une éducation
numérique pour tous fortement portée
dans le département et dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines se veut actrice des enfants
quand on regarde l'impact chez eux le ca
augmente leur créativité numérique ça
augmente leur autonomie et ça augmente
leur confiance en soi trois conditions
très importante pour augmenter les
résultats scolaires
l'objectif c'est de c'est à la fois de
parfaire la formation des enseignants
qui est une formation continue
la technologie évolue les outils évolue
donc les usages des volets d'une part et
c'est aussi de porter ces enseignements
directement au coeur des classes en
accueillant des classes et en les
accompagnant dans leurs projets la ville
d'elancourt est reconnu comme ville
pilote et laboratoire d'expérimentation
en matière d'éducation numérique depuis
2003 dans l'actualité du jour également
depuis ce matin 8 heures une dizaine
d'infirmiers du service des urgences de
l'hôpital privé de trappes est en grève
le personnel et dénoncent une surcharge
de travail sur vingt postes 13 sont
actuellement vacants et ne sont pas
encore remplacer les grévistes demandent
notamment une prime en raison de ce
manque d'effectif
il s'agit d'un mouvement de 48 heures
qui peut être reconduit en cas d'absence
de réponse concrète de la part de la
direction
attrape toujours venez vous confronté
demain mercredi à des simulateurs de
conduite ou encore des parcours simuler
sous l'emprise d'alcool ou de
stupéfiants un forum de sécurité
routière est organisée à la salle du
conseil communautaire de saint quentin
en yvelines c'est de 13h30 à 16h et
s'est proposé par ce qu'ils voient 16-25
la mission locale de saint quentin en
yvelines pour en parler fanny holveck
bonsoir conçoit alors vous êtes la
coordinatrice
du dispositif garanti jeunes pour la
mission locale de 50 ans ni venu puisque
c'est vraiment ce dispositif qui
organise ce forum de la sécurité
routière pourquoi justement organisé un
forum de la sécurité routière pourquoi
une mission locale organise un forum de
la sécurité routière
donc déjà c'est une deuxième édition
comme on a travaillé avec pas mal de
partenaires notamment we move avec son
pool de mobilité responsable et la
coordination départementale de sécurité
publique de la police nationale où on
tire le constat qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes donc qui ont un manque de
conscience des risques sur la route et
on voit aussi un fort taux
d'accidentologie de ce public par
rapport aux autres conducteurs
donc il ya un intérêt pour la mission
locale d'informer les jeunes c'était une
émission de de la mission locale
les objectifs de l'événement
sensibilisation information c'est ça
voilà et sur cette deuxième édition on a
rajouté l'intervention de la croix rouge
de saint quentin en yvelines qui vient
fera faire des initiations aux gestes de
premiers secours
donc il ya un travail avec de nombreux
partenaires
je le disais s'organise et plus
précisément par la 46 jeunes de la
mission locale qu'elle est ce dispositif
la garantie jeunes alors donc c'est un
accompagnement d'un an pour les jeunes
les plus en difficulté qui donc leur
permet d'avoir un accompagnement
renforcé cela il y a deux particularités
déjà ça commence par un a qu'une phase
collective d'un mois avec des ateliers
sur l'accès à l'autonomie de manière
générale logement mobilité santé et
aussi l'accès à l'emploi et deuxième
particularité pour les soutenir dans
leurs démarches mais aussi pour toutes
les problématiques qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer
ils ont une aide financière chaque mois
nous voilà pour le dispositif de la
garantie jeunes si on revient à cette
deuxième édition du forum quel est le
programme demain sur place quels
différents ateliers seront proposés
oui donc il y aura un espace d'affichage
de vidéos d'information avec donc la
police nationale we move donc mettra en
place un comment dire une simulation du
partage de la route avec un kit de
réalité virtuelle
il y aura un parcours avec des lunettes
qui permettent de simuler en effet comme
vous disiez
l'emprise de drogues de médicaments sera
pas sous l'emprise de drogue a annoncé
ça il faut le presser ses des lunettes
qui reproduit cet effet c'est ça tout à
fait il y aura un stand aux bars donc ça
permet d'être sensibilisés aux doses
légales de consommation d'alcool
un autre stand sur l'assurance
obligatoire se rendre compte
voilà deux des conséquences quand il n'y
a pas d'assurance en cas d'accident par
exemple voilà et enfin donc la croix
rouge qui sensibilisera aux gestes de
premiers secours mais aussi deux fois
dans la journée donc à 11h30 puis à
15h30
il y aura pour un groupe de 10 personnes
une heure d'initiation aux gestes de
premiers secours avec une remise
d'attestations mais à qui s'adressent
ces seulement aux jeunes du territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines vous pouvez
retrouver toutes les informations sur
les réseaux sociaux sur skyway 16-25
donc de 10h à 12h30 puis de 13h30 à 16h
et pour y participer on vient
directement sur place tout à fait et je
rappelle ce rendez-vous deuxième forme
de la sécurité routière demain mercredi
à la salle du conseil communautaire de
saint quentin en yvelines cet attrape le
rendez vous est fixé à 2 13h30 à 16h
même s'il ya des des initiations le
matin il ya aussi en fait cette année
l'année dernière c'était que en demi
journée
cette année c'est toute la journée voilà
et je rappelle mme fanny holveck merci à
vous que vous êtes la coordinatrice du
dispositif garanti jeunes pour la
mission locale de saint quentin en
yvelines sqy ouest 16 25 ans plus de la
fête qui lui était consacrée vendredi la
musique a animé tout le week-end à saint
quentin en yvelines samedi les
clayes-sous-bois organiser les clés si
belle plusieurs heures de musique au
parc de diane retour avec aurélie ronze
la voix de mélanie poker le cadre est
assez assez extraordinaire entre les
deux tours l'arbre magnifique derrière
il ya l'ambiance il ya les chanteurs
connus c'est gratuit et puis en plus
cela chaque année on a vu qu il rajouté
des animations être une découverte
justement ça sera bien
à voir c'est la première fois pourtant
j'ai habité longtemps clem et la
première fois ils avaient tous deux
bonnes raisons de venir pour l'édition
2019 les clayes-sous-bois avait vu les
choses en grand écran géant food trucks
et zone du public plus grande
l'adn ses excès surtout c'est que c'est
gratuit voilà c'est un des rares
festivals qui reste gratuit voilà c'est
aussi la volonté dans un parc naturel
aussi qui est absolument magnifique
voilà c'est aussi cette idée là et puis
c'est je crois que c'est surtout placée
sur le signe de la convivialité voilà
c'est un festival qui ne veut pas que
des experts de la musique quoi c'est un
festival populaire
ces artistes et groupes sur scène tout
l'après midi et la soirée comme vincent
vinel le local de l'étape anciens
candidats de the voice faisait son
premier concert à la maison
jeu très très très content très heureux
on a préparé le show comme il se doit et
on est prêt à faire du gros spectacle
le concert avec les civelles j'y suis
allé souvent bat déjà quand j'étais plus
petit ensuite j'ai présenté le concert
pendant deux ans en fait j'étais aux
premières
il ya six ans j'ai été voir avec les
sybelles il ya quatre ans j'étais sur
scène elle l'événement a attiré plus de
18000 personnes la soirée s'est terminée
qu'un retour dans les années 70 et 80
sur scène le groupe mythique nass wind
and fire
[Musique]
avec l'été arrive aussi lé fin de saison
des salles culturelles du territoire
mais avant de tomber le rideau certaines
vous attendent pour découvrir artistes
et oeuvres dont fort mélanie poquet sauf
pour votre coup de coeur de la semaine
votre choix s'est porté sur trois rendez
vous et oui du théâtre du cirque et du
théâtre trois oeuvres
à noter dans vos agendas le premier
rendez vous c'est une création et les
signer aurore et 20 metteur en scène les
artistes associés à la ferme de bel ébat
de guyancourt elle s'est intéressée à
une ou trice anglaise infrabel l'une des
toutes premières dramaturge
professionnelles européennes et la pièce
s'appelle une heureuse occasion et sur
scène la troupe de théâtre amateur de la
femme de belles et bae l'ensemble de
musique ancienne de léconi cipal pour en
savoir plus rendez vous samedi 29 juin à
20h30 un port royal des champs c'est une
oeuvre assez original que vous nous
présentez les mousquetaires passe en
mode séries à l'origine de l'idée le
collectif 49 mille sept cents à les
trois premières saisons de la série sont
à découvrir ce week-end à port royal des
champs on y retrouve tous les
personnages alexandre dumas milady athos
porthos ou encore aramis
mais les auteurs ont choisi de repartir
aux origines de l'oeuvre des personnages
elle s'intéresse notamment à la violence
d'état chaotique et sanglante deux
représentations sont prévues les 29 et
30 juin à 14 heures à noter c'est
important 6 heures de spectacle prévu
avec entracte pour le dernier
rendez-vous mélanie direction la mairie
that he a pour un voyage dans les
souvenirs et la nostalgie à celles que
l'on peut trouver dans le grenier d'une
maison dans ce grenier du collectif
entre nous trois mâts chinois vieux
tourne-disque et des canapés une
garde-robe des souvenirs qu'il faut
trier et en triant se remémore un peu de
tout regarder
[Musique]
alors pour découvrir les souvenirs que
ce grenier conserve direction la merise
de trappes de juillet prochain merci
mélanie on vous retrouve comme
d'habitude après ce journal dans le 7-8
culture puisque l'on parle culture ne
manquez pas la diffusion ce soir de ce
documentaire a joué onze une oeuvre
monumentale de nicolas sanhes revient
sur la réalisation la plus complexe de
l'artiste qui a notamment travaillé dans
la ville de trappes documentaire à
retrouver ce soir à 21h sur tv 78
rediffusion ce dimanche à 15 heures le
mois de juin est propice aux
célébrations dans les communes dimanche
23 joueurs c'était à la fête de la ville
à montigny le bretonneux et en cette
journée olympique la municipalité
organisait ses troisièmes olympiades
interquartiers les images signées miquel
et demi d'euros défi football mais aussi
tir à l'arc et trapèze pour la troisième
édition des olympiades de la ville
montigny le bretonneux proposait de
nombreuses activités et huit structures
gonflables et des parcours d'obstacles
de 30 mètres et est installée au centre
sportif pierre de coubertin un défi
avant tout amicale entre les huit
quartiers de la ville c'est participer
couverte à nous le disait participer aux
sports et découvrir aussi s'initier et
découvrir c'est très important parce que
le sport aujourd'hui fait partie de la
vie on se doit tous annoncent le douaron
peu tous pratiqué à une activité
sportive
à leur arrivée sur place les inhumant
temps reçu un bracelet à la couleur de
leur quartier et une carte chaque
participation à une activité rapporter
un point au quartier et beaucoup se sont
pris au jeu
vac c'est bien pour que les génies sort
tout ça correspond enfermés chez nous il
ya plein de photos gonflable pour
pour sauter pour rouler il ya plein de
choses à essayer nouvelle trapèze des
mobilités nouvelle avec à leur bord des
autres très sympa c'est bien pour
l'instant
je m'amuse bien et j'espère que je la
regardais mots gfr d'amis plutôt mon
quartier l'entousiasme de ce jeune
n'aura pas suffi après deux victoires en
deux éditions du village c'est le
quartier de lasours de riz qui a
remporté les olympiades de montigny le
bretonneux
et puis dans le même mouvement trappe en
fait a fait le plein samedi près de
15000 personnes sont venues à profiter
des manèges et des animations au stade
grave au thème cette année le cirque
ambiance avec aurélien le temps d'une
journée le stade gravaud a pris des
allures de fête foraine pour trappe en
fait une manifestation qui existe depuis
plus de 50 ans et qui se veut festive et
fédératrice
on s'adresse exclusivement dans un
premier temps aux trappistes bien
évidemment mais on a beaucoup de gens
qui viennent a aussi d'autres villes on
est toujours un peu sur l'éducation
populaire donc la participation très
important effectivement la culture pour
tous
pour cette édition 2010 9 une vingtaine
d'activités étaient proposées au public
les arts du cirque étaient à l'honneur
grand chapiteau avec spectacles mais
aussi des ateliers d'initiation
non c'était pas dur et pour peinture
c'était facile ça fait une petite sortie
c'est gratuit en plus faut pas se voiler
la face 1
et voilà les enfants sont contents ils
s'amusaient décor vu d'autres activités
au programme également des concerts et
des déambulations avec une météo
parfaite tous les ingrédients étaient
réunis pour le plus grand bonheur des
participants cette année je trouve qu'il
ya beaucoup d'activités à un cirque
il ya des vrais manège et voilà au fait
quelque part ça les fait sortir c'est
comme si tu étais quelque part dans une
fête foraine quoi tu m'as l'air avec
l'été qui n'ont mangé une glace et après
après on va y aller
est ce que tu es cas comme un jeune papa
papa une édition 2010 9 réussi pour
trappe en fait puisque cette
manifestation a accueilli plus de 14
mille cinq cents personnes
avant de vous laisser deux informations
déjà un rappel on l'a appris en fin
d'après-midi en raison du pic de
pollution et aussi de la canicule la
circulation différencier mise en place
pour la journée de demain en
ile-de-france ce les véhicules avec des
vignettes critères verte et aussi 1 2 et
3 pourront circuler à paris et dans les
communes limitrophes comprises dans le
périmètre intérieur de la 86è les
contrevenants s'exposent à une amende de
135 euros
et puis un mot de football après
l'arrivée de laurent fournier sur le
banc laisse fois ci enregistre une
nouvelle recrue de poids au milieu de
terrain en provenance de laval mounir
obbadi vient de s'engager pour deux ans
avec le club yvelinois pensionnaire de
nationale 2 formé au paris saint-germain
l'ex international marocain de 36 ans
est passé par monaco lille ou encore
vérone en italie
originaires de chanteloup les vignes il
comptabilise plus de 350 matches en
professionnel
c'est la fin de ce journal replay sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]